good morning John let me take you back
to let me take you back to Sunday of
this week I'm tired but I'm elated
VidCon has gone very lots of amazing
things happen YouTube announced that
everybody who makes money on the YouTube
platform can email a real person get a
response with the 24 hours Eva were very
excited about the launch of the Internet
creators guild and the crash course
curriculum materials a community at the
conference felt cohesive and supportive
of each other and all the little
problems that seemed really big at the
time got solved or dealt with really
quickly by a great team of staff and
volunteers who I'm just so pleased to
work with so it's Sunday Sunday evening
and I'm waiting a lot of my favorite
rollercoaster anywhere in the universe
space map and I'm pretty sure that the
little tickle in the back of my throat
isn't just from screaming for three days
straight you know I take a medicine that
suppresses my immune system so I get
sick a lot I deal with it it's no big
deal or the time I get back at the hotel
an hour or so later I'm full on muscle
aches and chills dragged myself outta
bed the next morning get on the plane
and immediately fall asleep and as we
are descending the first leg of my
flight I awaken to a pressure building
in my head I swallow to pop my ear
nothing happens we continue to descend
the pressure continues to build I'm
swallowing I'm yawning a massaging of
chewing I'm doing all the things nothing
is working the pain the pain the pain it
goes from pretty much like I stubbed my
toe but it's in my ears but pretty much
my top experience of acute pain which is
when I shattered my toe when I was
playing basketball that my shoes I do
that by the way so the thing never
happens it never pops in a can't hear
very well out of one of my ears as we're
on the ground and see out of the pain
subsides
I get on another plane it's fine on the
way up on the way down again but in both
ears this time I'm sitting next to a
stranger he doesn't know what's going on
with me I'm trying not to have outward
signs but I'm like crying and I'm
basically losing my mind so long story
short I ruptured both my eardrums good
news is apparently this happens fairly
frequently super painful but it gets
better I told you this whole story
mostly because I went out to get
Vietnamese food last night and I got a
fortune cookie I'm about 70 percent of
my normal hearing right now this is the
fortune I got you will be rewarded for
being a good listener this week Oh
fortune cookie why are you being so mean
to me everything that happens inside of
my head is very loud breathing chewing
my heart beating everything outside
that's another thing I found out this
week and I can't believe I didn't know
this is that all normal pain relievers
interact very badly like are literally
dangerous to take if you have ulcerative
colitis I don't know
told me this I'm taking a bunch of
dayquil and ibuprofen and suddenly my
colitis starts acting up and I'm like
this too at the same time that one I got
that nighttime sniffling sneezing
coughing aching stuffy head fever I can
no longer no never again remember you
will you hey remember what I said we're
going to get a really big announcement
at VidCon that it was going to be super
important for people who live nearby or
inside of Boston this February to
celebrate ten years ten years of
vlogbrothers we are going to be bringing
this community part of it into the real
world with a thing called nerdcon
nerdfighteria it is as close as we're
ever going to get to bringing
nerdfighteria into the real world gonna
have concerts and talks and panels of
games and a live recording of dear Hank
and John we have a ton of super cool
people there Charlie McDonnell Maureen
Johnson the perfect strangers George
Watsky Meghan tonjes
Ellie Grassley Lindsey doe for the five
awesome girls if you're from the old
days we are going to have a really weird
cool time it's not going to be anywhere
near as VidCon to be clear much smaller
more intimate event so it will probably
sell out pretty quickly we're also doing
one weird thing during registration it's
a little unfair that the only people who
get to come to things like this are
people who happen to have a spare $60 so
as you check out if you are able to you
can provide either a half or a full
scholarship for another nerdfighter to
come for free obligations for whose and
to get those scholarships will come in a
later time once we know how many we have
thank you to all of you for being a part
of this community especially those who
are not going to be able to come out to
nerdcon nerdfighteria you will be there
in spirit we will hold you in our hearts
John I'll see you on Tuesday